That's conducted experiments.
Just go and Google these two words.
Donald Trump,
what did you get when you googled them?
Well,
I'm sure you found lots of results about
his latest tweets,
his latest bold statements,
or maybe his latest sexual scandal,
but you probably have to click to the
seconds or even the third page to find
out anything about what is actually one
of his biggest political bats.
We're talking about something that might
change the international economy.
It might change the price of oil and the
fate of two countries.
Yes,
dear viewer,
I'm talking of course,
or maybe not.
Of course it was on that third page of
Google.
I'm talking about the Iran sanctions.
This is such a complex matter,
but we will make not one,
not two,
but three videos covering all of the
various caveats.
In today's video,
we're going to focus on one question.
What does the nuclear program have to do
with the price of oil,
and at the end of this video,
you're going to see where I'm coming
from.
As with every good story,
we should start by introducing our
characters.
The first one is of course,
the Islamic Republic of Iran,
a country known for Persian carpets,
uranium enrichments,
and of course oil.
Yup.
Iran has the fourth largest amount of
dinosaur juice reserves on the planet,
but that is not all.
If you've been subscribed to visual
politic for a long time,
you already know that there are
different types of crude oil.
For example,
if you want to extract an oil barrel in
Scotland from the North Sea,
you've got to build a sea platform.
You've got to make a super deep hole
that goes below the bottom of the ocean
and then use a rocket technology to
refine it.
In total,
a barrel has an extraction cost of more
than $44 in Iran.
The extraction cost is less than a
fourth of that.
Along with Saudi Arabia,
they have the cheapest oil on the
planet,
so well,
what's the problem?
Jeep all sounds great.
Well,
they can't sell it to to most countries.
Iran's economy is virtually isolated
from the rest of the world.
This means they can only export about 3
million barrels per day of oil.
Although due to the threat of sanctions,
there are currently only exporting about
1 million barrels.
Yeah,
per day.
That might seem like a lot,
but it's nothing.
If we compare it with the 7.5
million barrels per day currently being
exploited by Saudi Arabia,
which is currently producing nearly 11
million barrels per day in total,
it's an the,
you might be wondering.
Well,
Simon,
who is Iran's worst enemy is America.
Ryan Stone.
Sure.
Well,
you're wrong.
Aaron's arch enemy is actually Saudi
Arabia and yeah,
I know both countries or Muslim,
both countries follow strict religious
principles and both countries consider
human rights.
Well optional,
but not all of Islam is the same.
And Iran,
Shia Muslims are the majority.
While Saudi Arabia is a Sunni Muslim
country.
So do you surmise they hate each other,
but that's another story for another
video.
So what is Saudi Arabia's problem?
Well,
despite having oil and lots of money,
there are,
comedy is the edge of collapse.
Basically they spend all of them.
I need living like a hip hop artists.
On a Friday night.
And since they don't export anything
other than than oil,
anytime the price of the barrel of oil
goes down on the market,
their economy goes into panic mode.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
who's Saudi Arabia's best friends?
Well,
this is actually when America comes into
the picture.
Okay.
All right.
So the relationship between Uncle Sam
and the Saudi royal house is not as
wonderful as it seems from the outside.
During the Obama administration,
the White House puts some pressure on
the Saudis and tried to get closer ties
with Iran.
This is how that nuclear deal came
about.
Now the president is Donald Trump,
and from the moment he stepped into the
Oval Office,
trump has made it clear who is ally in
the Middle East was this is why his
first official trip was to the Saudi
capital of Riyadh.
Even now,
after the alleged murder of a Saudi
journalist in Turkey,
Donald Trump is trying to avoid making a
from condemnation,
but the best proof of his friendship
with the Saudi royal house are the Iran
nuclear sanctions.
Yep.
You heard that,
right?
So now you might be wondering,
well,
what does Saudi Arabia have to do with
Iran sanctions?
What does oil have to do with any of
this?
Well,
today we're going to answer these
questions,
but before we do,
as always,
let's take a look back at the head
straight
political ball.
Remember this date,
April,
2015 this was the date when Barack Obama
signs the Iran nuclear deal.
Basically in this agreement,
America,
China,
Russia,
and the European Union said that they
would start trading with Iran if they
stopped then nuclear program.
This explains why from one day to the
next oil exports from Iran almost
doubled.
Just have a look at this
chops
to Obama's deal.
Iran.
Ron was making 1.8
million barrels a day after the deal.
Iran increased it to as much as 3
million barrels.
Then Yukon's bill,
how was Spain,
France,
and other European countries,
and what happens when the oil supply on
the international market increases?
Well,
the price of a barrel of oil drops and
you just have a look at this other
chart.
At the moment,
the deal was signed.
The brand's barrel with 67 US dollars
just a year later.
It was twice as cheap.
Of course,
there are many other factors that could
explain this price drop,
but Iran,
it was definitely one of them,
but the,
hold on just a minute because this
really is just the beginning of our
story.
Now,
longtime visual politics subscribers,
which you should be subscribed below,
you already know how hard it is to
extract oil.
You need technology,
you need companies,
you need money and lots of it.
In other words,
if the National Iranian oil company
wanted to produce more oil barrels,
they needed investors,
and this was when the real financial bom
APP,
so lately draw,
you're Rabia is considering an IPO of
Saudi Aramco,
potentially the world's most valuable
company.
Let's pause right there.
Why is this news so important for our
story?
Well,
let's rewind a little further.
Okay.
Financial explosion.
Now I'm going to ask you a question.
What is the world's biggest company?
Now,
many of you might reply with apple or
Coca Cola or,
or maybe some big bank somewhere that
you might've heard of.
Well,
actually,
it's none of those things.
The world's biggest company is actually
Aramco.
Okay?
This is Saudi Arabia's national oil
company.
However,
they waste your time finding it on the
stock market.
It's not only is it not public,
Aramco is owned by the Saudi royal
family.
Nonetheless,
having the world's biggest company,
it doesn't mean you can't go bankrupt.
You'll see as oil prices go down,
Saudi Arabia is in dire straits.
They need to diversify their economy.
They've got to gain wealth from other
things other than just petroleum.
So how can they do this?
Well,
essentially the big idea was to start a
hedge.
Sorry.
Audio Rabia
wants to grow its sovereign wealth fund
to over $2 trillion.
Now,
weird as this might seem,
this wouldn't be the first time a whole
country invested in businesses.
In fact,
the world's biggest hedge funds actually
belongs to the Norwegian government.
This audis,
they just want to make something
similar.
So this all sounds pretty good.
So what's the problem,
Simon?
Well,
they need money then.
It's 20 of the world's biggest company.
Where did you get money from?
Well,
you just sell something,
your company on the stock markets and
that gives you all of the cash you need.
It's basic business.
This way.
The Saudi royal family would kill two
birds with one stone.
First they make money and they also keep
Iran from getting that juicy investors'
money.
You remember how he told you when in
2016 around once invest investors to
build new oil rig swelled before those
investors would consider Iran,
Saudi Arabia at wanted to dangle a suite
at piece of candy in front of their eyes
and that was of course Aramco,
but hold on a minute,
it wasn't that
he see listing a company on the stock
market is great cause all of a sudden
you get a lot of cats.
The problem and your turn for being a
publicly listed company,
you must make your books publicly
available after all,
no one would invest in a company if they
can't see that company's financial
statements to see how they're making
money and how they're spending it.
In other words,
you've got to be transparent and you
have to remember that transparency is
the least favorite word of the Saudi
royal house.
You'll see for decades,
the Saudi Monique's have basically been
using Aramco for anything they wanted,
policies,
luxury,
and those sorts of things that you
probably don't even want to know about,
but this is not the problem.
According to Prince Mohammed bin Salman,
also known as mbs Aramco is worth $2
trillion.
That means that this 5% he wants to sell
would be worth $100 billion.
Nonetheless,
as soon as he started talking about the
IPA,
all these various financial analyst
started making their own estimations and
they essentially said $2 trillion bad
with the price of oil falling like this.
Are you smoking crack?
Best case scenario,
best case,
you're looking at one point 2 trillion
or one point 5 trillion.
F we're being rarely,
rarely generous.
Hello?
Where's that financial explosion that
the Aramco Ipo was supposed to be?
Basically the game,
nothing but a buzzword and he's,
I'm in the past year.
Anyone asked Prince Salomon,
what he thought about this.
It basically kind of respond like this.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
man,
it's legit.
Another day.
I'm busy with print stuff at later,
man.
Later.
Hold on a moment because this is still
not the end of our story.
Okay.
A crater in the markets.
Here's another day for you to remember
that may at 2018 this is the moment when
trump broke the Iran deal and announce a
new economic sanctions.
Yep.
Not only that,
he also promised secondary sanctions
against those countries that would not
comply.
In other words,
if any country wants to buy oil from
Iran,
well,
they'd also have to deal with Uncle Sam
and June off Agastya that that also
includes the end higher European Union.
Other countries don't really catch.
I know for example,
has said,
you know,
I don't care trump,
whatever,
we're going to buy it all from Iran.
India,
the second largest client has said that
they will try to reduce imports,
but they can't.
100% stopped buying all from the country
of the ayatollah.
Nonetheless,
it seems like the EU will have to follow
Donald Trump to the latter even if they
don't want to,
but this as a matter we're actually
going to discuss in the next video.
The truth is nowadays Europe is buying
more than 1 million barrels from Iran
every day.
This means if we take it ron,
out of the equation,
we have a whole 1 million barrel order
of it.
Somebody has to fill because you know
one thing is absolutely clear throughout
all of this,
everybody needs that sweet,
sweet dinosaur juice and I bet you can
guess now who is very,
very happy to be filling that role.
Boy,
trump pressures Saudi Arabia to increase
oil production.
Nevertheless,
Saudi Arabia just increased its
production by 600,000
barrels.
Russia has done say by 200,000
and if you do the math,
it's not tricky.
You get 800,000
barrels.
We still need more to fill that huge
void and you probably also remember what
happens when we reduce the oil offering
on the international market.
Oh Yeah,
supply and demand kicks in and the price
of that oil barrel goes up.
Let's get back to our Brent shot.
If you pay attention,
you will see that right after trump
started talking about the Iran
sanctions,
the dyno juice,
it went up to $80 in other words,
things are starting to go really,
really well for the Saudi economy.
Okay.
Saudi Arabia sovereign wealth fund
raises $11 billion loan.
So what does this mean?
Well,
two things.
On the one hand,
the Saudi royal family now has a lot
more breathing space for that.
Aramco IPO,
the company is now profitable enough
that they can wait before going to the
stock market.
So I'll lazy prints,
he doesn't need to worry about it.
On the other hand,
if they could keep the oil barrel at 80
US dollars,
it would be way easier to hit that
initial valuation of $2 trillion.
And while that explains news like this,
Saudi Crown Prince has ipo for oil giant
Saudi Aramco will happen by early 2021
meanwhile,
there are two things we should cover.
First,
the Islamic Republic of Iran is at the
edge of economic collapse.
This is leading to protests,
social unrest,
and an authoritarian regime.
That is having a very bad situation.
Seconds we have the big question is the
EU gonna comply with trump sanctions?
The debate,
it really couldn't be hotter these days.
You asked to protect firms from donald
trump's sanctions against Iran.
So now the question is,
do you think we are at the beginning of
the end of the ayatollah's regime?
Do you think the European Union will
keep from buying oil from Iran?
Well,
we'd love to read your thoughts and
theories and in the following videos
we're going to see quite how much they
match with our own.
Also do visit them,
reconsider media website,
the podcast that provided the vocals in
this episode that are not mine.
In the meantime,
don't forget that we published brand new
videos every week,
so do hit that subscribe button and the
little bell icon so you'll see a
notification anytime we post an update.
And if you like this video,
please do give us a thumbs up.
As always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more,
my lovely voice,
don't forget to checkout that we
consider podcast@reconsidermedia.com
we consider as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your abused by
providing context,
but we don't do the thinking for you.